alikum isn't the wom's are allowed to
make a jamat in
Sal a question that are women allowed to
make jamat in Salah Point number one yes
they can join a jamat of the Jens but
separate and complete segregation if a
gent is praying an Imam is praying and
if they want to join they can join they
should be in the behind rules that these
are the best Row for a woman is the last
row and the worst row is the front row
and for the man the worst row is the
last row and the best row is the front
row So based on the various Hadith that
a woman can join in jamat if a gent is
reading but there should be separate
segregation of sexes and proper facility
I think the main question is can women
form a jamat by themselves only a woman
jamat yes they can but the rules and
regulations slly differ there can be a
only ladies jamat led by a lady
Imam a lady can be a Imam but there are
slight differences there that if a lady
is Imam in a gent normally a gent Imam
stands in the front and the first row
stands behind him in Islam when a lady
stands a lady stands in the same
row it's in the same R she
stands so there very
that with she led the prayers of all the
ladies so a woman can be an IM also so
if there are no gents if she can't go to
the mosque and only ladies in the house
or in some office place and they want to
read they can read there's no problem
hope answer the question